Priya Singh: Today’s focus: design system button variants.
Avery Kim: Any blockers from last time?
Avery Kim: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Samira López: My take is we split design system button variants into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: My take is we split design system button variants into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on design system button variants; start with a spike.
Priya Singh: Action: create test plan.
Priya Singh: Action: write migration.
Samira López: Risk: data migration for design system button variants.
Samira López: Let’s not block on design system button variants; parallelize testing.
Riley Chen: Risk: data migration for design system button variants.
Riley Chen: I think we split design system button variants into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Risk: scope creep for design system button variants.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on design system button variants; ship a thin slice.
Riley Chen: Action: set up dashboards.
Noah Williams: Infra-wise, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Noah Williams: We should add a feature flag on design system button variants.
Samira López: Action: create test plan.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on design system button variants; start with a spike.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on design system button variants; parallelize testing.
Noah Williams: Any risks we’re missing? on design system button variants.
Noah Williams: From QA perspective, Security review is likely.
Avery Kim: Risk: data migration for design system button variants.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on design system button variants; parallelize testing.
Riley Chen: I propose we split design system button variants into two subtasks.
Samira López: Risk: scope creep for design system button variants.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on design system button variants; parallelize testing.
Jordan Patel: Risk: scope creep for design system button variants.
Avery Kim: Infra-wise, Security review is likely.
Noah Williams: Quick update on the scope on design system button variants.
Riley Chen: Action: set up dashboards.
Riley Chen: Risk: scope creep for design system button variants.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on design system button variants; parallelize testing.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on design system button variants; ship a thin slice.
Priya Singh: We should add a feature flag on design system button variants.
Noah Williams: UX needs a final pass on design system button variants.
Noah Williams: Let’s capture action items clearly on design system button variants.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on design system button variants; parallelize testing.
Jordan Patel: From design side, Specifically for design system button variants.
Samira López: My take is we split design system button variants into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: Action: write migration.
Avery Kim: We should add a feature flag on design system button variants.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on design system button variants; ship a thin slice.
Priya Singh: Okay, who can take ownership?
Priya Singh: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Noah Williams: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.